[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans cette édition
spéciale préparée par la rédaction de TV
78 nous sommes le lundi 25 avril voici
les titres Emmanuel Macron réélu
président de la République il arrive
également largement en tête dans les
Yvelines avec
71,05% des voix mais le candidat lrem
perd des électeurs par rapport au
scrutin de 2017 au contraire Marine Le
Pen recueille plus de 40 000 voix
supplémentaires depuis la dernière
élection présidentielle dans le
département
26,51% c'est l'abstention de ce deuxième
tour dans les Yvelines la mobilisation
est certes supérieure à celle du niveau
national mais le chiffre est un record
jamais aussi peu d'électeurs ne s'était
déplacés aux ions depuis le scrutin de
1969 record absolu en la matière avec
une abstention de 32,17%
. et puis direction Drocourt dans cette
émission ce petit village du nord des
Yvelines n'a pas réussi à départager
Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen au
deuxième tour de la présidentielle une
égalité parfaite pour les deux candidats
avec 50% des suffrages obtenus
et nous nous projeterons aussi sur
l'élection qui est présentée comme le
troisième tour de cette élection
présidentielle le scrutin des
législatives au programme les 12 et 19
juin prochain avec mon plateau aussi
tout au long de cette édition les
journalistes de la rédaction de tv78
j'accueille déjà Nicolas dandry bonsoir
bonsoir Grégory qui nous fera un point
dans un instant notamment sur la
participation et même plutôt
l'abstention puisque c'est le chiffre à
retenir et dans les Yvelines lui aussi
sera avec nous tout au long de cette
édition par visioconférence c'est
Raphaël Mata du Vigneau bonsoir
professeur de droit public à
l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines Paris Saclay
et on vous voit régulièrement sur TV 78
chaque vendredi est dans la rubrique
quelle légale King parce que vous faites
également partie des surligneurs et dans
légal checking chaque vendredi vous
décryptez l'actualité et les propos des
personnalités politiques voilà c'est
parti pour cette édition spéciale
[Musique]
et le premier point de cette émission
avec Nicolas sur les chiffres de la
participation dans les Yvelines on va
même parler au contraire je le disais
d'abstention car c'est la donnée qui a
marqué le deuxième tour de cette
élection présidentielle oui je vais vous
proposer d'abord de revenir il y a deux
semaines un rappelez-vous 22% des
électeurs Illinois ne s'était pas
déplacées aux urnes et cette fois-ci
c'est 26,5 % des électeurs qui ont boudé
les ions pour ce second tour même si ce
score est légèrement inférieur à la
moyenne nationale de 28% c'est quand
même un record dans les Yvelines depuis
les élections de 1969 qui opposé Georges
Pompidou et Alain power où ont dépassé
les 32% d'abstention à titre de
comparaison en 2017 on était à
23,6%, 17,7% en 2012 et 13,8% en 2007
mais quelles sont les communes Nicolas
où on a le moins voté et bien pas de
surprise c'est le même phénomène qu'au
premier tour ce sont dans les quartiers
populaires où les électeurs ne se sont
pas déplacés et si on trouvait un fort
taux d'abstention c'était notamment les
villes où on avait voté Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
débile qu'avec la scène le candidat LFI
en première position à plus de la
majorité absolue au premier tour ont
dépassé les 30% d'abstention à noter par
exemple aux Mureaux
44,4% d'abstention chantent tous les
vignes
41,34% ou encore Mantes-la-Jolie avec
41,58 % et au contraire où est-ce que
les électeurs yvelinois se sont le plus
mobilisés mais du côté des communes ou
les électeurs se sont mobilisés c'est
les mêmes villes que pour le premier
tour Voisins-le-Bretonneux avec 18,22%
d'abstention Viroflay avec 19,69%
Croissy-sur-Seine avec 20,58% en tout
cas ce sont toujours des villes où
Emmanuel Macron dépasse les 70%. voilà
allez-y oui
il était 20% en premier tour et il est
passé à 4,2% au second tour merci à
Nicolas pour ce premier point voilà pour
ce constat on va tenter de trouver
quelques explications une abstention
record a fait le Mata du Vigneau du
jamais vu on le disait pour la France et
aussi pour les Yvelines depuis le
scrutin de 1969 comment on peut
expliquer le désintérêt de ces électeurs
sur cette élection présidentielle
comment vous l'analysez
des intérêts pour les électeurs à de
multiples explications à vos avis la
première c'est que effectivement les les
candidats au second tour en tout cas ne
suscitaient pas forcément une forte
adhésion d'une part c'est vrai qu'il y a
le rejet de Marine Le Pen d'un côté et
de l'autre côté la façon dont Emmanuel
Macron a pu éventuellement gouverner
enfin la perception de la méthode de
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron et puis
les crises des gilets jaunes et
coronavirus donc ces deux phénomènes ont
créé je pense d'une part un phénomène
d'abstention et de rejet d'autre part
aussi et ça c'est très important je
pense que ce soit au premier tour au
second tour la question de la de la
qualité c'est très fort comme mot et de
la qualité des candidats il est vrai que
par rapport à d'autres élections
précédentes le personnel politique
l'offre politique était peut-être d'une
qualité endossaï ne répondait pas aux
aspirations aux attentes et je pense
qu'il y a un décalage entre d'un côté
les programmes président les programmes
politiques et de l'autre le quotidien
les attentes les aspirations des
citoyens qui voilà qui ne se retrouvent
pas dans leur dans les dans l'offres
politiques et donc cet ensemble génère à
mon avis une abstention on a vu il y a
différents taux d'abstention selon les
villes et aussi une progression du vote
blanc est-ce que à votre avis aura un
avant et un après élection
présidentielle de 2022 ce que ça peut
peut-être amener à des évolutions des
olives des évolutions législatives de
plus en plus d'électeurs demandent
notamment la prise en compte du vote
blanc
alors oui je ne sais pas si la prise en
compte du vote blanc est une bonne chose
par contre ce qui est clair et ça le
président réélu l'affirmer des hier soir
c'est que il y aura une nouvelle méthode
de gouvernement et je pense et ça ça a
été dit par beaucoup il est fort
probable qu'une réforme
constitutionnelle ou même simplement une
réforme législative et lieu pour au
niveau des législatives en tout cas
mettre en place un système de
proportionnelle ce qui permettrait
peut-être de d'avoir une meilleure
représentativité de la de la population
de la configuration politique générale
et ce qui permettrait finalement aux
personnes d'aller voter et d'avoir
l'espoir l'aspiration d'être représenté
à minima par un ou une députée à
l'Assemblée nationale ce qui permettrait
là aussi de redynamiser cette cette vie
politique ça c'est un premier point et
un autre point aussi important c'est que
il faudra probablement réinventer
la manière dont on conçoit la démocratie
donc on conçoit la citoyenneté et la
participation et ça c'est une c'est une
chose importante sur le long terme ça se
ressent pas d'une baguette magique un
coup de baguette magique mais il va
falloir entamer probablement des
négociations sur les questions de
démocratie participative de
proportionnelle le recouvrir au
référendum voilà bref redynamiser je
pense que c'est un moment important on a
pu certains le dire on a failli arriver
au pire j'en sais rien mais pas c'est
pas mon rôle de le dire mais en tout
état de cause je pense que c'est un bon
élément un bon moment pour démocratique
un nouveau souffle et comme pour la
France entière Emmanuel Macron remporte
le deuxième tour de cette élection
présidentielle dans les Yvelines les cas
et plus conséquent dans le département
71,05% des voix pour le président
sortant 28,95% pour Marine Le Pen qui
gagne tout de même 40 000 électeurs de
plus depuis 2017 face à cette victoire
d'Emmanuel Macron et à la hausse elle
dévoie en faveur de Marine Le Pen il y a
des satisfactions à la fois d'un côté
chez les représentants et Benoît de la
République en marche mais aussi du
rassemblement national Nicolas on va
commencer par le camp des vainqueurs
effectivement et direction un bar à
Versailles où les militants de la
République en marche est réunies il est
20h et regarder l'ambiance
[Applaudissements]
et ses estimations seront confirmées
durant la soirée Emmanuel Macron
remporte cette élection avec 58% des
suffrages au niveau national un résultat
largement dépassé dans les Yvelines le
président de la République sortant
enregistre plus de 71% des suffrages
dans le département a noté son meilleur
score yvelinois Béa Croissy-sur-Seine
comme au premier tour plus de 80% des
électeurs ont choisi Emmanuel Macron
autre résultat au-delà des 80% à
Viroflay à noter aussi que
Saint-Germain-en-Laye devient un fief de
la République en marche avec notamment
Arnaud Péricard le maire de la ville qui
soutient Emmanuel Macron et ben dans
cette commune il recueille plus de 78%
des voix des résultats satisfaisants
pour les militants ibnois de la majorité
présidentielle
très heureux de cette réaction pour un
second mandat on va pouvoir continuer
les projets qui sont en cours je suis
[Musique]
très très bon c'est une très belle
victoire
on peut dire il y a 5 ans c'était autre
chose c'était ce système de cela 58 %
c'était une espérée une large victoire
d'Emmanuel Macron dans les Yvelines mais
une large victoire a relativisé d'abord
parce que vous en avez parlé il y a
l'abstention et le vote blanc puis par
rapport aussi aux résultats de 2017 et à
la montée du rassemblement national le
président de la République avait été
avait recueilli en 2017
70% des voix et en 5 ans en fait il perd
6 points de pourcentage aux dépenses de
Marine Le Pen une situation qui devrait
être prise en compte dans le second
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron il faut
écouter les gens il faut comprendre faut
faire plus de pédagogies faut avoir un
gouvernement qui soit élargi où ils
n'ont pas l'impression d'être exclu le
score d'Emmanuel Macron diminue par
rapport à celui 2017 mais en même temps
il a fait preuve de responsabilité il a
compris entre les deux tours les enjeux
du point de vue climatique il a
également été à l'écoute des différents
candidats du premier tour qui n'avait
pas été sélectionné pour le deuxième il
va falloir que dans ce deuxième
quinquennat on traite l'ensemble des
sujets qui préoccupent toutes ces
Français qui les conduisent à voter pour
une candidate qui manifestement
ne peut pas être présidente de la
République de mon point de vue et pour
moi c'est un poste de contestation on
continuera à plaider nous pour la
proportionnelle parce que je crois
qu'aujourd'hui dans cette nécessité de
rassembler le pays il faut que
l'ensemble des Français puissent être
représentés et je crois que quelque part
le message qui a été aussi envoyé ce
soir avec cette abstention c'est que les
Français ont besoin d'avoir une
représentation quel que soit leur idée
quel que soit leur candidat à
l'Assemblée nationale au Parlement alors
Raphaël mataduvignon vous avez parlé de
réformes constitutionnelle
institutionnelle qu'est-ce que doit
faire Emmanuel Macron dans la principale
préoccupation des Français aujourd'hui
notamment le pouvoir d'achat et puis
réconcilier ces deux France qu'on a vu
durant ce scrutin la France rurale
périurbaine et puis la France qui gagne
disons qui inclus dans la mondialisation
et plusieurs urbaine alors je ne suis
pas le mieux placé pour dire président
Macron ce qu'il doit faire par contre
effectivement il y a deux éléments sur
lesquels je pense pouvoir apporter un
éclairage le premier élément c'est comme
j'ai dit tout à l'heure la réforme
institutionnelle je pense que
on ne pourra pas échapper durant ce
quinquennat à une réforme de en tout cas
du pouvoir législatif probablement une
proportionnelle alors à ce côté
majoritaire avec une dose de
proportionnelle je n'en sais rien mais
en tout état de cause et les propos du
président du modèle des Yvelines sont
tout à fait justes il va falloir trouver
les instruments démocratiques permettant
de redonner finalement ce que je disais
tout à l'heure de redonner une pleine
effectivité à ce qui fait le coeur de
notre constitution de notre cinquième
république la souveraineté appartient du
appartient à souveraineté appartient au
peuple il exerce soit par ses
représentants soit par le référendum et
donc il va falloir trouver les
instruments juridiques ça c'est au
gouvernement de le
permettant justement cette
ce renouveau donc je suis assez
favorable une proportionnelle ou en tout
cas un système assez proche ça c'est la
première élément un autre élément
sur on va dire le programme politique
je n'ai pas l'envissement de dicter
Emmanuel Macron ce qu'il doit faire par
contre je pense pour essayer de faire
de permettre aux Français de se
retrouver sur des sur des valeurs sur
des principes communs je pense qu'il y a
cinq ou six chantiers essentiels la
santé la justice
l'éducation
l'écologie l'environnement
et l'économie évidemment alors ce sont
des mots très faciles mais je pense que
ce sont des grands chantiers sur
lesquels le futur gouvernement devra
insister et intensifier son action
peut-être même prioritaire des actions
prioritaires et je pense que ce sont des
thématiques qui permettront aux Français
à tous les Français de se retrouver et
là peut-être finalement redonner du goût
à la politique aussi
si elle sera la réponse d'Emmanuel
Macron dans les prochains jours alors du
côté du RN Nicolas quels sont les
enseignements par rapport aux résultats
de du rassemblement national justement
et bien le rassemblement national
progresse dans les Yvelines un chiffre
Grégory résume bien ce phénomène 40
000 électeurs supplémentaires pour
Marine Le Pen par rapport au second tour
de 2017 une progression de 6 points de
pourcentage au niveau départemental sur
les 259 municipalités des Yvelines la
candidate du rassemblement national
arrive en tête dans 28 communes et sur
cette progression je vous propose
d'écouter la députée européenne Yves
linoise Mathilde et le délégué
départemental du rassemblement national
Laurent Morin la campagne de Marine Le
Pen pendant ces 8 mois de campagne a été
une campagne de qualité une campagne de
proximité elle a su établir un lien de
confiance je pense avec une grande
partie des Français je pense qu'il y a
eu un transfert dans l'entre-deux tours
de certaines personnes de gauche
j'imagine que certains électeurs de
Mélenchon qui gardent quand même une
logique sociale ce sont reportés sur
nous d'où un peu ce saut ne serait-ce
qu'en voix et on retrouve le même
phénomène qu'au premier tour ce sont les
zones rurales qui ont voté pour la
candidate du rassemblement national
notamment les zones qui sont limitrophes
avec le département de l'Eure de
l'Eure-et-Loir et puis aussi divine avec
l'Eure-et-Loir plusieurs scores
significatifs dans les Yvelines d'abord
ce petit village de Flacourt la candidat
du Rassemblement national obtient 61%
des suffrages résultat plus systémiques
significatif avec deux communes du nord
des Yvelines avec plus de 2000 habitants
Porcheville et Bonnières les deux
communes
c'est dans ces deux communes Marine Le
Pen arrive en tête avec 51% des voix
pour bonnir sur scène et un peu plus de
51,5% à Porcheville il y a une
progression aussi du côté des grandes
villes oui dans les grandes villes elle
progresse et on en a choisi une la plus
symbolique c'est Versailles la
candidatérine
noter c'est une percée notable pour la
candidate du rassemblement national à
Versailles elle dépasse les 30% des
suffrages elle gagne 7 points de
pourcentage par rapport à 2017 si on
fait le comparatif un scrutin où elle
avait récolté plus de 23% des voix donc
vous voyez 7 points qui sépare ces deux
résultats et à ce propos on écoute à
nouveau Mathilde d'Android et Laurent
brun c'est sans doute dans cette
sociologie si particulière de la ville
de Versailles comme à Saint-Germain et
comme dans l'est des Yvelines peut-être
les faits les faits bénéfique de la
candidature d'Éric Zemmour et un report
de voix plutôt satisfaisant je pense
dans ces vies il a dans les Yvelines
ce terme même de droite à une à une
importance dans des territoires tels que
Versailles c'est vrai que les scores de
monsieur Zemmour est intéressant dans ce
coin donc je pense que à la limite ça
sera peut-être des
éventuels discussions très mais très
localisées dans l'entre-deux tours avec
des gens si tu enfin les équipes de
Zemmour si tu es autour de Versailles
Raphaël m'attadu une question toute
simple quel est l'avenir du
rassemblement national notamment dans un
territoire comme les Yvelines
[Musique]
pour être honnête je n'en sais rien
je n'en sais rien tout dépend en réalité
de la de la réalité des personnes qui
ont voté pour Marine Le Pen c'est à dire
que le vote Le Pen est-ce que c'est un
vote véritablement d'adhésion c'est la
vraie question en réalité on le voit on
le sait beaucoup d'électeurs de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon se sont reportés sur Marine Le
Pen aux alentours quelle est la
véritable part des électeurs de Marine
Le Pen c'est la vraie question
maintenant je pense que ce soit au
niveau des Yvelines au niveau national
contrairement à ce que l'on entend ou ce
que l'on lit un petit peu partout il y a
quand même un constat que l'on doit
effectuer et dresser depuis plusieurs
années maintenant c'est que le vote pour
Marine Le Pen en tout cas pour le
rassemblement national de manière
générale il est stable il est stable et
il progresse donc on doit se poser
certaines questions alors l'avenir du RN
je n'en sais rien mais je ne pense pas
qu'il est voué à disparaître je pense
qu'il est voué à avoir une place assez
importante et je vais dire centrale dans
dans l'échiquier à droite
et je pense que pour l'instant en tout
cas pour le moment il est incontournable
voilà après la place je ne peux pas vous
dire évidemment mais on constate que le
vote malgré tout progresse il est stable
donc il est là il est là c'est pas
simplement un accident
la question après le premier tour a fait
le matin du union on disait que Marine
Le Pen stagnait finalement dans les
Yvelines elle avait gagné qu'un seul
point par rapport au premier tour en
2017 là le constat est différent puisque
on voit qu'il y a gagne 40 000 électeurs
si on se base sur le deuxième tour de
2017 dans les Yvelines donc vous le
disiez ce que comment vous commencez à
avancer on peut le voir plutôt comme un
vote de rejet à Emmanuel Macron plus
qu'un vote d'adhésion c'est ça
je pense que l'ampleur du score de
Marine Le Pen hier est lié
principalement à un vote de rejet de
d'Emmanuel Macron ça c'est c'est une
évidence mais il y a quand même une base
structurelle assez importante pour elle
malgré tout on rappelle que le
rassemblement national avait un ancrage
local entre 2014 et 2020 puisque
Mantes-la-Ville a été la seule ville
d'Île-de-France à avoir un maire
rassemblement national
[Musique]
et si les électeurs étaient hier appelés
à faire un choix entre Emmanuel Macron
et Marine Le Pen les habitants de
Drocourt eux n'ont pas réussi à trancher
dans la commune yvelinoise les deux
candidats sont arrivés à égalité
parfaite lors de ce deuxième tour on
retrouve sur place Mathilde Franco et
Patrick Jacques de dix MEDA
trouve un petit village situé au nord
des Yvelines avec
33 habitants
ants au
second présidentiel il y a eu 50% pour
Emmanuel Macron et 50% pour Marine Le
Pen nous allons aller à la rencontre des
habitants et bon moi je suis pas déçu
avec les promesses qu'il a fait monsieur
Macron je parlais avec une copine pour
les retraites et tout ça c'est pas très
décevant enfin moi j'ai voté pour Le Pen
Le Pen aussi moi j'aurais pensé que Le
Pen n'aurait passé avant et Macron est
tout ce qui dit et je sais pas c'est pas
toujours vrai
mais ça m'étonne je suis pas vraiment
surprise les résultats peut-être même
que je pensais que le peigne passerait
davantage puisque elle avait vu fin
meilleur score que Macron au premier
tour voilà après ce que je pense des
résultats pas forcément
hyper satisfaite voilà j'ai j'ai voté
pour ce qui me semblait être le mieux
j'ai pas voté pour une conviction
absolue
sur la personne qui se fait deux
personnes qui se présentaient quoi voilà
après on verra bien ce que ça donnera
j'espère que Monsieur Macron
pris note c'est ce qu'il a dit hier
maintenant je crois qu'on attend
beaucoup pour lui quoi
je suis actuellement avec le maire de
Drocourt Dominique Pierret bonjour
bonjour alors dans votre village il y a
eu 50% de voix pour Emmanuel Macron et
50 % de voix pour Marine Le Pen comment
est-ce que ça vous surprend
non ça me surprend pas disons que
effectivement
si vous voulez on est pas loin donc de
la commune de Mantes-la-Jolie j'ai fait
quand même donc 24 logements sociaux sur
la commune et je me souviens très bien
quand on a fait donc ces logements et
bien on avait des réactions où les gens
avaient un petit peu peur qu'est-ce que
l'on va avoir comme population etc donc
il y a la proximité de Mantes-la-Jolie
qui est quand même dans toutes les têtes
des droits courtois vous l'aurez compris
malgré cette égalité parfaite entre les
deux candidats au second tour de la
présidentielle les Draux courtois et les
Draux courtoises attendent beaucoup du
second quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
édition spéciale de la rédaction de TV
78 pour revenir sur le résultat des
élections présidentielles avec un focus
particulier sur le département des
Yvelines on a vu les réactions côté la
République en marche côté rassemblement
national je rappelle également que tout
au long de cette édition il y avait avec
nous par visioconférence Raphaël Mata
Duvigneau qui est professeur de droit
public à l'université Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines et également
plateau avec nous qui on va rejoindre
juste une brasier de la rédaction de TV
78 bonsoir Justine alors dans les
Yvelines d'autres élus locaux en dehors
de ceux de la République en marche et du
rassemblement national ce sont exprimés
ils ont fait et vous faites le point
justement sur les les différentes
réactions de ces hommes politiques ou
femme politique yvelinois exactement
alors en majorité les élus locaux ont
félicité le président Emmanuel Macron
pour sa réélection certains étaient
rassurés du résultat mais résultat
mitigé car beaucoup de votre portée pour
ce second tour vers Emmanuel Macron pour
faire barrage à l'extrême droite et non
pour ces idées donc je vous propose
d'écouter des propos recueillis parmi la
ni poker tout en apportant des
félicitations très républicaines bien
sûr je n'apporte pas un blanc ça malgré
tout à tout ça je pense que le résultat
est un résultat qui
ne satisfait pas tout le monde dans la
mesure où effectivement on peut
ressentir tout un tout un report de voix
qui n'était pas forcément dans dans ma
positif total pour manuel Macron assuré
de voir que le l'extrême droite n'est
pas passé malgré toutes les tous les
tous les messages et toutes les craintes
qu'on a pu avoir dans les derniers temps
parce que effectivement on comprenait
bien que cette fois-ci les choses ne se
poseraient pas de la même façon que lors
des élections précédentes ou le
rassemblement national ou Front national
était présent et on avait vu ce parquet
clairement affreux républicain la cette
fois-ci les choses étaient plus troubles
d'autres élus se sont exprimés via les
réseaux sociaux c'est le cas de Pierre
Bédié président de la Fédération elle
les républicains 78 et également
président du conseil départemental des
Yvelines il a réagi en disant je cite la
réélection du président Macron est un
soulagement puisqu'elle prouve que
l'espérance républicaine est encore la
plus forte mais cette espérance ne peut
pas continuer de fonder l'idéal national
que si le président donne l'élan aux
réformes nécessaires et puis également
bien sûr Valérie Pécresse un candidate à
l'élection présidentielle 2022 pour les
républicains a également réagi l hier
soir via les réseaux sociaux toujours
via Twitter je cite j'adresse mes
félicitations républicaines à Emmanuel
Macron sa victoire ne doit pas masquer
les fractures de notre pays conduisant
Marine Le Pen un score
inéditée des Yvelines et actuellement
conseillère municipal de la commune de
Vélizy-Villacoublay Justine en début de
journal de du taux d'abstention très
fort taux d'abstention record depuis
1969 dans les Yvelines les élus locaux
que pense-t-il de ce sujet justement
alors d'une manière générale il tire un
peu la sonnette d'alarme un taux vous
l'avez dit c'est un taureau tort record
pardon d'abstention qui s'explique par
le fait que les citoyens en question ne
sont pas sentis pour ce second tour
représenté et donc soit il ne se sent
pas senti concernés ce dimanche soit ils
ont voulu montrer qu'ils n'étaient pas
satisfaits la réaction justement de
représentants locaux micro de de Mélanie
pocket et Patrick Jacques delixmude
l'essentiel a été préservé l'extrême
droite ne prend pas le pouvoir en France
c'était ce pourquoi nous étions
essentiellement mobilisés depuis le le
premier tour mais la situation
démocratiquement est inquiétante une
partie importante des Français ne
croient plus dans le système
démocratique beaucoup se sont abstenus
on l'a vécu en particulier ici à Trappes
et on constate que l'extrême droite
maintenant dépasse les 40%. même la
jeunesse est surtout la jeunesse ne
ressent pas cette nécessité de faire
entendre sa voix et pourtant c'est le
seul
mois en France donc
j'ai pas l'impression que ça s'améliore
donc il va falloir faire un gros travail
blanc sur ce second tour que sur le
premier ou dans l'avion quasiment pas
donc là il y a tout de même une
expression d'insatisfaction qui sort
merci Justine Brazier de nous avoir
partagé ces réactions et au lendemain de
cette élection présidentielle résultat
de ce deuxième tour plusieurs candidats
déjà battus lors du premier tour battu
aussi lors de ce deuxième tour parlent
du troisième tour de l'élection
présidentielle les élections
législatives qui vont arriver les 10 et
19 juin prochain on va parler dans un
instant des enjeux Raphaël mataduvigneau
le résultat de la présidentielle on l'a
présenté à Emmanuel Macron qui a été
réélu mais qui est en perte de vitesse
c'est également le cas dans les Yvelines
le rassemblement national qui gagne du
terrain on peut aussi parler de la
percée de Jean-Luc Mélenchon lors du
premier tour est-ce que c'est à votre
avis un avant-goût de ce qui peut se
passer pour les élections législatives
ou au contraire c'est un tout autre
scrutin et on repart à zéro entre
guillemets
en fait il y a une
double réponse et juste avant si vous me
permettez j'aimerais juste revenir sur
les témoignages que l'on convient
d'entendre ce qui est ce qui est vrai
c'est que depuis longtemps et en fait ce
n'est pas depuis quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron c'est depuis très longtemps en
réalité il y a un problème en France
d'acceptabilité de la décision
démocratique et on le voit avec le la
multiplication des des mouvements
sociaux des manifestations dans les rues
dès qu'une loi est adoptée on n'est pas
contents donc on descend dans la rue et
il y a je remets pas en cause le droit
de manifester évidemment mais ce qu'on
observe c'est vraiment une
multiplication une prolifération si vous
voulez de ces de ces contestations
parfois violentes d'une décision
démocratique et légitime et ça c'est un
vrai un vrai problème et je pense que
l'un des enjeux d'Emmanuel Macron du
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron va être
essayer de redonner cette confiance dans
le système démocratique voilà je ferme
la parenthèse concernant les enjeux des
législatives évidemment un présent de la
République ne peut pas gouverner s'il
n'a pas de majorité au Parlement puisque
il va nommer le Premier ministre en
fonction de la majorité parlementaire
plusieurs choses à voir le la
configuration du système législatif fait
que cet instant innominal à deux tours
et donc on vote en fonction de personnes
dans des circonscriptions électorales et
donc là la question du localisme va
beaucoup jouer c'est à dire que les
électeurs vont malgré tout essayer de
voter pour quelqu'un qui va
véritablement les représenter ça c'est
un premier élément et donc parfois on va
voter pour quelqu'un qu'on connaît par
quelqu'un qu'on a l'habitude de voir et
donc peut-être que ce système de rejet
ne fonctionnera pas on peut penser aussi
que les Français sont malgré tout
légitimistes c'est à dire qu'ils ont
même par défaut à voter élu un président
ils vont essayer de lui donner une
majorité en tout cas une majorité va
essayer de lui confier les reines du
pouvoir je pense que le Front national
n'aura pas ne pourra pas prétendre en
avion ne pourra pas prétendre avoir une
majorité à l'assemblée par contre ce qui
est c'est le jeu des alliances entre LFI
le PS les écologistes peut-être les
communistes et peut-être que cette cette
alliance je sais pas comment on pourrait
l'appeler cette alliance pourrait donner
du fil à retordre à
je ne dis pas que
ce n'est pas mon propos je n'en sais
rien je ne suis pas devin mais en tout
cas je pense qu'il est fort probable que
le camp de gauche mené par Mélenchon
obtienne un nombre très important de de
députés tout l'enjeu pour chaque parti
politique sera d'obtenir au minimum 15
députés pour avoir un groupe
parlementaire et avoir les droits qui
s'y qui sont afférents et ensuite
dernier point c'est que finalement d'une
certaine manière il vaudrait mieux pour
Emmanuel Macron qu'il n'est pas une
grande majorité comme il a pu l'avoir de
en 2017-2022 mais une majorité
confortable mais pas écrasante comme ça
ça l'obligera à négocier à
discuter avec une autre partie et ce qui
finalement sera peut-être
des compromis et ce qui sera aussi
peut-être l'acceptable pour la société
et alors quels sont les enjeux de ces
élections et à quoi pourrait ressembler
ce scrutin dans le département des
Yvelines je vous propose d'écouter
Patrice Karmous directeur de
l'information de TV 78
Bédié dont son fauteuil de députés mais
en 2017 la situation nationale était
différente François Fillon avait réalisé
dans les Yvelines près de 28% des voix
ça n'a pas été le cas cette année de
Valérie Pécresse qui donc son propre
département n'a réalisé qu'à peine 8,5%
des voix cette fois c'est Emmanuel
Macron qui est arrivé à en tête avec
près de 33% au premier tour et 71% au
deuxième tour cette nouvelle donne aura
évidemment des conséquences sur les
législatives on peut penser qu'elle
favorisera les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle c'est d'ailleurs ce que
semble penser le responsable du MoDem et
maire de Villepreux Jean-Baptiste
amonique au micro de Nicolas dandry
j'annonce rien sur les législatives
parce que je pense que il y a encore une
grosse campagne une nouvelle campagne
qui va commencer mais on a la
possibilité de réaliser quelque chose
d'important comme on l'a fait en 2017
sur ce département c'est un département
qui est profondément ancré au centre et
donc il va falloir continuer à
travailler sur l'ensemble des
circonscriptions dans tous les
territoires des circonscriptions à la
fois dans les quartiers populaires à la
fois dans les quartiers dit plus riches
et encore parler là aussi à tous les
Yvelinois reste que dans certaines
circonscriptions des circonstances
particulières risque de peser c'est le
cas par exemple de la 11e
circonscription celle de Bois d'Arcy
Delancourt et de Trappes elle était
gagnée en 2017 par l'actuel ministre de
la Ville Nadia et puis elle est revenue
au cours d'une partiel en 2020 à
Philippe benasaya qui s'y est présenté
sous l'étiquette LR or c'est dans cette
circonscription que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
au premier tour des présidentielles à
réaliser ses meilleurs scores remportant
par exemple plus de 60% des suffrages
attrapent d'où l'idée qu'un candidat de
gauche les filles ou apparentés puissent
remporter cette circonscription qui fut
une guerre nous n'oublions pas celle de
Benoît Hamon reste à trouver le candidat
ou la candidate qui fera l'unanimité sur
son nom ce qui n'est pas gagné une chose
est sûre ce candidat ne sera pas à lire
AB qui préfère conserver ses fonctions
de mer de trappe comme il l'a confié à
Patrick Jacques de dismud moi je ne
serai pas candidat puisque je suis maire
de trappes et pleinement à ma tâche on
peut pas être mère et député je ne le
souhaite pas je suis contre le cumul des
mandats donc je me concentre sur trap
mais j'estime qu'en tant que maire de
trappe j'ai une responsabilité pour
soutenir encourager les candidats qui se
présenteront et pour faire en sorte que
ces candidats soient les candidats de
toute la gauche et pas seulement d'un
parti donc j'y arriverai dès demain
reste à savoir quel sera l'attitude de
la droite des macronistes et de la
gauche républicaine face à ce danger
d'une victoire mélenchoniste
réussiront-ils à s’accorder sur le nom
d'un seul candidat est-ce que Philippe
Benassaya candidat LR ou députée sortant
LR mais qui vient du giscardisme et
Macron compatible c'est de la réponse à
ces questions que dépendra le sort de
cette circonscription autre
circonscription
observé la troisième circonscription des
Yvelines celle de la selle Saint-Cloud
du Séné de Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche
Béatrice Pirot la députée sortante se
verrait bien faire un deuxième mandat
comme elle l'explique à Nicolas dandry
je suis candidate à l'investiture c'est
sûr puisque j'ai fait un seul mandat et
j'aimerais bien en faire un deuxième
évidemment pour l'instant rien n'est
statué pour l'instant on a travaillé que
sur les présidentielle on attend avec un
patience l'annonce des investitures
seulement voilà l'actuel ministre de
l'éducation nationale Jean-Michel
Blanquer lorgne sur cette
circonscription au grand dame d'ailleurs
de la plupart des députés sortant lrem
qui voit d'un mauvais œil ce parachutage
mais n'y est-il pas là à un risque de
division qui pourrait profiter à la
droite LR qui a longtemps tenu cette
circonscription voilà une autre question
qui se pose quand on rassemblement
national finaliste de cette élection
présidentielle avec Marine Le Pen il
reste même si la progresser relativement
faible dans ce département bah il n'est
pas de la terminer que troisième au
premier tour derrière Emmanuel Macron et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et même si elle
réalise d'assez mon score dans le 8e
circonscription celle de Mantes-la-Jolie
de Mantes-la-Ville ou même dans la 9e
qui est une circonscription plus rurale
dont le sortant est Bruno Milliane elle
obtient quand même moins de 40 % des
suffrages trop loin pour réaliser une
surprise au législative peut-être une
surprise au législative Raphaël
mataduvigneau ça a été rappelé dans
cette chronique de Patrice Carmouze la
République en marche avec son allié du
MoDem avait remporté 11 des 12
circonscriptions yvelinoises en 2017
avant de perdre la 11e alors d'une
législative partielle en 11e
circonscription qui a été gagnée par le
député LR Philippe Benassaya ça semble
compliqué aujourd'hui de revoir un
raz-de-marée à r.e.m comme on avait pu
le voir en 2017
je pense au niveau des Yvelines même si
je ne connais pas vraiment la bien la
sociologie des Yvelines mais en tout cas
au niveau national je pense qu'on n'aura
pas de raz-de-marée c'est
sûr il y a trop de défiance vraiment
trop de défiance et de rejet de la part
d'une partie de la population de
concernant la politique menée par le
gouvernement donc il y aura pas de
raz-de-marée il y aura un nombre
important de pertes c'est sûr et puis en
fait ce qui va être important de voir
c'est finalement va récupérer les voix
certaines voix ETREM est-ce que ce sont
les LR ou alors est-ce que c'est s'ils
arrivent à se reconstruire suite à
l'épisode de la présidentielle où est-ce
que c'est le ce que je vais appeler le
Bloc des gauches mené probablement par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon voilà en fait
finalement l'enjeu va être va être là et
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est d'avoir une majorité mais pas trop
pas trop imposante
comme ça il va pouvoir mener sa
politique mais il devra composer avec
les autres il devra discuter il devra
faire des compromis et ce sera beaucoup
plus simple donc pour vous répondre très
sincèrement très simplement bon il y
aura pas de marée il y aura simplement
je pense une une majorité relative une
majorité point et voilà mais comme ça a
été rappelé aussi les Français sont
légitimistes donc ils vont malgré tout
donner une je pense une majorité
Emmanuel Macron oui allez-y terminez
et comme en 2002 finalement lorsque
Jacques Chirac était opposé à Jean-Marie
Le Pen finalement il a eu une majorité
même s'il y a beaucoup de personnes
rejetaient sa politique également les
Français lui ont malgré tout donner une
majorité pour gouverner juste après avec
un autre enjeu forcément qui sera à
prendre en compte celui de l'abstention
rappelle juste les chiffres en 2017 à
47,42% d'abstention premier tour dans
les Yvelines
54,68% au deuxième tour merci Raphaël
Mata du Vigneau d'avoir été avec nous
tout au long de cette édition spéciale
merci à vous et je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur de droit public à
l'université Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines Paris c'est clair membre des
surligneurs et je rappelle aussi qu'on
vous retrouve chaque vendredi sur TV 78
dans la rubrique légale check-in qui
décrypte l'actualité et les propos des
personnalités politiques voilà c'est la
fin de cette édition spéciale merci de
votre fidélité merci à Justine Brazier à
Nicolas dandry de la rédaction de TV 78
merci à la l'ensemble de la rédaction et
aussi à l'équipe technique de TV 78
cette édition spéciale et bien sûr à
revoir en replay sur notre site Internet
et notre application mobile belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]